hello my name is reto Meier welcome to
this week in Android development on
Monday August 19 2013 last week the
Android developer relations team visited
London serving up some knowledge to
students at Android camp and introducing
the GDG London to the world of android
gaming on this side of the pond Chet was
back again for a look at using cartoon
animation techniques in a brand new dev
bite while further south
australian-based colleagues invited you
back stage for a QA on how to make your
apps beautiful when not backstage Jeff
was front and center showing us how to
optimize layouts with hierarchy viewer
and our favorite intern doll does
everything we need to know about image
pixelization next week we have a flood
of new device for you starting with a
guide to listview dragging the
rearranging with Daniel ensuring your
apps work on large display devices and a
new series of devbytes from yours truly
as I explained how to make your data
transfers more efficient for fans of the
longer format we've got a nude Android
design in action this week and hack and
Todd will be getting their game on on a
new episode of game on that will
introduce you to the wonderful world of
OpenGL ES 3.0 that's all for this week
in Android development be sure to check
out this week's dev bites and join us
for our live shows which you can find as
always at developers.google.com/live /
android and everyone is waiting waiting
on you